les kerguelen un archipel d'origine
volcanique presque aussi grand que la
corse demeuraient inconnues jusqu'à la
fin du xviiie siècle saisi la bri et une
faune vierge de tout contact avec les
autres terres éléphants de mer manche
aux otaries phoque baleines et de
nombreuses colonies d'oiseaux marins
puis l'homme est arrivé jusqu'au début
du 20e siècle chasseurs de phoques de
baleines ont fréquenté l'archipel
massacrant la foule
mais dans leur sillage les colons ont
amené pire que la peste de nouvelles
espèces qui n'avait rien à faire là
les rats d'abord les cales en était
pleine
puis des lapins pour manger
[Musique]
enfin au milieu du 20e siècle on essaya
de développer l'élevage du mouton rennes
mon flux
[Musique]
ce bateau n'est pas un bateau comme les
autres c'est le bateau du bout du monde
le marion dufresne
aujourd'hui sa destination les îles
kerguelen
[Musique]
ces espèces ont modifié les écosystèmes
et aujourd'hui les scientifiques sont
préoccupés à l'époque des colons l'état
des connaissances ne permettait pas de
prévoir les bouleversements écologiques
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
de nos jours grâce à une prise de
conscience collective on tente de
réparer au point qu'aujourd'hui un poste
de chargé de mission sur les questions
de l'environnement a été créée sur place
maxime est attendu là-bas au bout du
monde pour remplacer l'actuel
responsable
je pars pour 13 mois donc un hivernants
ils appellent ça donc toute une année
donc moi j'étais intéressé par sa part
ce coin là j'ai eu trois semaines à peu
près pour faire mes valises et depuis le
temps que je suis au courant que je pars
et puis le départ donc bon relativement
rapide quand même donc un peu la course
ce jeune homme est un vat autrement dit
un volontaire civil à l'aide technique
depuis la fin du service national
c'est une forme de coopération offertes
aux jeunes en outre mer un engagement à
long terme
il faut bien quinze jours pour franchir
les 3500 kilomètres qui sépare les îles
kerguelen de la réunion
sans doute en at il fallu davantage aux
chevaliers de kerguelen lorsqu il en fit
la découverte en 1772
sans doute aussi fallait-il davantage
d'inconscience et d'esprit davanture à
l'époque pour se hasarder dans ses
parages inconnu où le vent règne en
maître
[Musique]
les îles kerguelen forme d'un archipel
au sud de l'océan indien et constitue
l'un des cinq districts du territoire
des terres australes et antarctiques
françaises
cet archipel d'une superficie d'environ
7000 200 kilomètres carrés est constitué
d'une île principale la grande terre et
d'un golf qui concentre plus de 300 kg
ici rien n'est facile
d'ailleurs on a cost pas on atterrit
à
[Musique]
autrefois on appelait cette île l'île de
la désolation
c'est dire que le climat n'y est pas des
plus favorables
balayée par des vents incessants
saisines ont connu plusieurs tentatives
de colonisation mais aucune population
permanente n'a pu s'y développer ce
n'est qu'en 1950 une base s'est
installée définitivement
kovacs salut ça
le nouveau pape environnement là c'est
ça bienvenue à cannes elle côtoie en
direct ruth tu te montres tâchant ouais
c'est à gauche là
dans la tente d'être présenté à celui
qui doit remplacer le petit nouveau
prend ses quartiers pendant 13 mois
c'est là qu'il vivra
on est quand même venu à kerguelen
parce qu'on aime quand même un petit peu
la solitude c'est vrai qu'on est là
aussi pour en profiter des moments de
calme le seul avec la nature mais bon là
pour l'instant je commence tout juste
donc pour l'instant tout est beau tout
se passe bien
peut-être que oui dit si effectivement 6
7 mois là je commencerai un amant là
c'est en avoir un peu marre de côtoyer
toujours les mêmes personnes mais vous
normalement enfin ça m'inquiète pas
[Musique]
m
la base de port aux français est une
base de vie elle accueille en permanence
60 à 100 personnes qui se relaient
chaque année les animaux cohabitent avec
les hommes en bonne intelligence
[Musique]
autrefois persécuté par les anciens
colons il semble n'avoir gardé aucune
mémoire de ce passé cruel sans doute
n'ont-ils aucune conscience non plus de
la bienveillance dont ils font désormais
l'objet
[Musique]
depuis ces derniers mois le principal
protecteur des animaux ici ces sept
hommes benoît benoît et l'actuel v seat
et environnement au sein de la base
aujourd'hui il va devoir former maxime
pour assurer la relève
il lui reste un mois pour transmettre à
son successeur presque son élève les
connaissances qu'il a acquises depuis un
an
ç'a eu ce maintien ok c'est toi qui
remplace alors partir décembre un peu
moins de passation monique fléchi
passion tu expliquer un peu le rôle à
une bataille en demande sur quel nom n'a
pas que donc en fait c'est eux qui
s'occupent de la chasse sur l'île en
fait c'est toi qui fais passer des
formations pour pour la chasse pour
qu'ils puissent eux mêmes à les chasser
si vous l'avez chasser des espèces
sécurité introduites les principales et
aussi pour le mouflon donc ça te fera
des dz aussi pour toi pour aller chasser
une fin pour réaliser tant qu homme
plein de régulation
donc est ce que tu as déjà chasser le
gros gibier ben non pas spécialement
mois vers chez moi c'est surtout du
petit gibier donc
j'ai pratiqué essentiellement cette
chance là et puis bon grand gibier j'ai
pu participer à quelques battues mais
c'était vraiment anecdotique
là aussi bon de levante environnement tu
chasses si tu aimes ça tu chasses au
moins dix 10 voire 15 jours par mois
durant pratiquement toute l'année donc
tu fais que ça tout le temps c'est vrai
que c'est le rêve de tout le monde de
venir chasser ici toute l'année
être payé pour ça mais écoute la has est
vrai que ça fait bizarre la quittes
arrivé en hélicoptère et tous les
premières petites rafales de vent bien
sympathique
et puis bon la base en général bon ça
fait un peu bizarre car c'est pas c'est
pas très reluisant après c'est vrai que
bon là en voyant la chambre et tous les
petites chambres
on vient de quitter une belle maison là
en métropole et tout et puis là on se
retrouve dans une petite piaule
minuscule est bon on va on va faire avec
toute façon la majorité du temps ça sera
sur le terrain ça sera ailleurs donc j'y
passerai pas ma vie donc on ne sera pas
de problème on perd toute notion ici
d'un tu vois moi je m'habitue j'avais
pas de barbe et pas de cheveux longs ici
tu fais comme il ya voilà tu laisses
aller parce que tu sais que ça aucune
incidence tout le monde fait pareil donc
bon c'est comme ça c'est ben c'est
qu'arrivé
[Musique]
pour leur première formation chasse
benoît et maxime doivent récupérer les
fusils mais ici les armes sont soumises
à un contrôle très strict on ne sait
jamais bonjour monsieur
c'est donc le chef du district qui
distribue armes et munitions
combien de cartouches pour la formation
maintenant hâte responsable de
l'armurerie donc il faut pas faire non
plus n'importe quoi donner les clés à
n'importe qui et c'est mais garder quand
même parce que donner les fusils aux
gens qui vont chasser bon il faut quand
même faire attention à pas le donner à
n'importe qui donc
mais bon ça fait partie de ma mission
sur certains gays chasse sur district de
kerguelen non régulièrement benoît
organise une formation de chasse
destinée à ceux qui participent aux
opérations de régulation qu'ils soient
ou non détenteurs d'un permis
là on est plus on est plus dans la gamme
des jouets on est encore égard des armes
de chasse
c'est en gros c'est des arbres sniper
donc
ça peut faire très très mal par contre à
porter avec des balles avec le fusil un
fusil liste tu me après quand bébé tu
armes bah tiens je pense que celle que
tu veux benoît profitent de l'exercice
pour jauger son nouveau protégé est
mesurée par exemple son aptitude à
manier les armes évalué sécurité une des
espèces importées qui est le plus
développé c'est bien sûr le lapin est
malheureusement pour ce petit rongeur
c'est lui qui fait les frais des
premiers exercices sur cibles mouvantes
david le berger local apprend également
aux initiés à dépecer le gibier benoît
demandé à maxime de bien suivre
l'organisation de cette formation car
très bientôt c'est lui qui devrait
officier
[Musique]
les lapins ont été introduits ici en
au départ il faisait office de
nourriture mais il n'a pas fallu
longtemps à cet animal très fécond pour
envahir la totalité de l'archipel
aujourd'hui ils pullulent
seules les parties de chasse que ce soit
pour la formation pour la consommation
peuvent représenter une menace pour lui
[Musique]
dans cette baie que l'on appelle la b2
rakhmanov 120000 coupe ou 200000 man
show viennent chaque année pour se
reproduire
ce sont des manchots royaux
chaque mâle se met en quête de la
compagne idéale peu à peu les couples se
forment
ces animaux sont capables de se
reproduire au coeur d'une multitude de
congénères en s'identifiant à leurs cris
de leur accouplement naîtra un oisillon
dont le moins que l'on puisse dire est
que l'apparence mettra du temps à égaler
celle de ses parents cet animal encore
plus étrange qui pente aussi la baie de
rakhmanov c'est le pop chat autrement
dit jean baptiste pons biologiste
animalier dont le travail consiste à
étudier la population des chats des
kerguelen
mais ces animaux jadis domestiques sont
retournés à l'état sauvage depuis bien
des années
pour les capturer jean baptiste doit
poser des pièges garni d'un appât une
fois les chats capturés
direction le labo ou avec un autre
scientifique
thibault une série d' analyse et mise en
oeuvre on a introduit le chat au milieu
des des années 50 pour lutter contre les
allées population de rats une population
de rats qui sont arrivés par les bateaux
par les premiers faux qui est par les
ravitaillements sur les bases
il a eu un impact positif sur les
populations doha puisqu'elles ont
quasiment disparu de l'île
mais une fois que les populations draps
étaient trop basses le chat s'est
rabattu sur les populations d'oiseaux on
ne peut pas dire que c'est le chat des
kerguelen c'est une espèce de chats part
entière c'est un chat domestique revenus
à l'état sauvage
pour l'instant les seules différences
con
qu'on a c'est plus au niveau
physiologique c'est à dire que c'est des
chats qui sont très musclé bien
charpenté comme on dit la sélection
naturelle elle joua à 200%
donc à partir de là on se retrouve avec
des chats avec des des coûts des
mâchoires très musclé justement plus au
pouvoir tuer des lapins des chats qui
monte des débats rocheuses de plusieurs
centaines de mètres en courant et en
rebondissant d'un rocher à l'autre avec
les conditions les conditions de vie
pour les chats ici à kerguelen
ah oui c'est pas ce que c'est c'est
atroce où la durée de vie moyenne d'un
chat ici c'est on va dire que ça
s'approche autour d'eux à les cinq ans
rapport au quinze années d'un chat
domestique en métropole en france après
la série d' analyse les chats sont
relâchés près de l'endroit de leur
capture
la plupart du temps ce sont des lapins
qui servent d'appât pour capturer les
chats jean baptiste les chasses en
différents endroits de l'archipel où ils
pullulent mais ça n'est pas pour autant
qu'ils sont faciles à chasser la plupart
du temps les ans nous je travaille sont
relativement de plates donc les lapins
nous voient dans d'assez loin
soissons relativement encaissés et dans
ce cas là ya pas forcément d'habitat
très favorable pour la pince et beaucoup
de pierriers et c'est donc donc c'est
pas toujours évident
oh
on a cinq sites on tourne sur chaque
site environ tous les quinze jours
chaque fois que je change de site il
faut que j'aille chassé pour armer les
pièges
ouais dans l'après midi je veux tu
m'aimais 15 lapin après je rentre et
puis je procède aux audi section d'une
certaine manière
jean baptiste n'arrête jamais la traque
car la photo c'est une autre forme de
chasse pour laquelle il a aussi quelques
talents ici à kergane le plaisir n'a
quand même pas mal pour des amoureux de
la nature c'est d'abord la photo
une manière principalement la photo de
nature donc ici c'est un terrain de jeu
idéal c'est vraiment excellentes de
photographier la vie qui se passe ici
avec les ambiances les lumières les
paysages grandioses
[Musique]
on
non plus
[Musique]
la veille du départ pour la chasse la
première mission de maxime est simple
aller prendre des informations à la
station météo
[Musique]
je lui disais ça je vais devoir là
demain encore manip dans le golfe le
couteau qui tombe bien j'avais lâché le
ballon on voit ça près ok pas de
problème ça marche donc ça va être un
peu sport hockey
[Musique]
quand on s'aventure loin de la base dans
une terre qui peut vite devenir hostiles
il faut prendre ses précautions et ici
la météo c'est une affaire de sécurité
pour les relevés de donner les ballons
sondes sont un allié très précieux or
ont lâché des ballons pour pouvoir
sonder l'atmosphère n'en comprend la
température au niveau du sol au niveau
du sol ça suffit pas il faut une fois
des températures au niveau de
l'atmosphère et on met tout dans un dans
un gros calculateurs avec une calcul des
prévisions et tout ça aussi bizarre que
cela puisse paraître c'est pour pouvoir
faire des prévisions même sur l'europe
il nous faut ce genre de données
les conditions météo peuvent très vite
devenir extrêmes mais plus que les
variations de températures s'élevant ici
qui peut devenir un ennemi
à cause de lui le temps et rapidement
change en or car guen en fin de compte
c'est assez simple on une seule journée
on peut avoir les quatre saisons on
aussi sur des températures toute l'année
aux alentours de - 2 - 3 jusqu'à + 7 +8
et la particularité c'est le vent on n'a
pas les plus grosses tempêtes du monde
c'est pas des cyclones mais le vent
souffle constamment tous les jours on a
des mois entiers où on a 30 jours de
vent supérieures à 30 noeuds c'est à
dire 30 jours de vent supérieures à 60
kilomètres/heure constamment constamment
c'est quand même très hostile et c'est
pour ça que le personnel ne restent pas
le plus que l'on peut faire ici c'est un
an après tout le personnel ait changé
peut-être qu'on ne tiendrait pas plus
longtemps
[Musique]
c'est ici sur l'île haute que se trouve
la colonie de mouflons que maxime aura
pour mission d'observer et de réguler
benoît le conduit dans une cabane qui
sera désormais son domicile principal
voilà sa cabane donc la cuisine en
chambre puis derrière ta le
d'études estime toujours que j'ai
l'habitude d'être donc tu veux le garder
oui un peu mais qu'un timbre higuain
si ça part vite surtout sur l'option 25
mois
première leçon pour max les essentiels
de la survie sur ce plan on ne peut pas
rêver plus un look il pourra utiliser
est une eau de pluie des plus purs
benoît mis au point une pompe pour
pouvoir en disposer quand le besoin s'en
fait sentir
[Musique]
sans plus attendre benoît veut montrer
le site à maxime et surtout tenter
d'approcher un groupe de mouflons pour
commencer le travail de régulation
introduit dans l'île au milieu du siècle
dernier
ces animaux ont trouvé ici un terrain
idéal à leur développement
lille est escarpé et bien sûr pas un
seul prédateur pour les menacer mais
pour les approcher c'est une autre
affaire non seulement on est très vite
repéré mais la vitesse de déplacement
des hardes rang l'approchent difficile
où les pentes abruptes du centre de
l'île rendent leur fuite très efficace
sans compter qu'une île on peut
indéfiniment en faire le tour
résultat les deux chasseurs marche déjà
depuis trois heures et toujours rien
[Musique]
cry ils ont dû passer par constitua ça
ça semble un peu la brebis qui a fait un
peu de bruit a fait ce soir ils viennent
à la tous les matins ils sont là ils
viennent se coucher dans les pâtes et
riz sur la wii ont atteint son soleil
il se régale
on y voir clair dans l'un d'entre eux
[Musique]
après là ça passe il faut connaître
passage tu vois tu commences à t'engager
dans les trucs comme ça
c'est un besoin
[Musique]
pour ce pc
pour ce que c'est
on a réussi un petit moment là pour
blizzard mais pour qui ça se tasse et
est donc illégal parce que tu as raison
ils sont jamais des trucs à l'est pas ce
programme alerte info qui seul qui
s'appellerait
vous
c'est bon à prendre je pense que
regardent
je compte amer
roger tu vas passer par le music du port
sud-africain 25 ans est qualifié par la
patrouille en deux bassins comme ça
matuidi sortir à temps ci de passer à
grimper comme celui ci ça se voit mal de
coins et vitaux pour la tête décès de ma
vie c'est la base ou derrière pierre dac
hollande c'est pas grave
ses vents maximums tu es prêt
ok
c'est bon
quant à eux se trouvent pas un peu qui
par prologue bassignana même paquet
on va coincer à la dépasser mais je vais
te montrer un peu commun comment faut
faire et puis l'homme a récupéré les
filets les cuissots et des épaules cet
animal restera sur place
mais pour enseigner la technique à
maxime benoit entreprend tout de même de
le dépecer donc éviter de tout le temps
en fait mettre en contact la viande avec
avec le sol pour éviter les maladies
puis c'est tout ici tout son sacre aime
pas grand-chose à grand chose
on a pas d'installation donc on est
obligé de faire ça sur le terrain c'est
pas évident
à la base c'était juste un couple de
mouchan tu vois donc qui sont venus de
paris du zoo de vincennes et c'était
dans les années 50
ils ont mis ce couple sur l'île et puis
tu vois quand tu m'as inclus que 40 ans
plus tard quoi tu as dit nous sommes
partout ouais la population a n'a pas
n'a pas de consignes et mêmes les
supports tous très très bien on essaie
de respecter le quota que tu iras
priorité des animaux qu'ils sont mais
qui sont malades si tu vois des animaux
malades mal formés boiteux on essaye de
garder les beaux les bobillier pour
faire des reproducteurs jeunes est une
centaine cet hiver là et c'est vrai que
c'était pas évident surtout parce qu'en
fait la missive en lacets menant c'est
beau il fait beau là mais l'hiver à
l'hiver la callas dès que c'est que de
la neige partout des grosses congères et
tous déjà le passage et qu'on a fait on
ne peut pas le prendre en hiver déjà
même les mouvements les vite parce que
c'est en fait il ya des plaques de glace
partout ce type de chasse
particulièrement difficile puisque basée
sur l' approche rend le travail de
régulation complexe et pour atteindre
les quotas
la tâche est ardue surtout pour un
chasseur seul mais aujourd'hui puisqu'il
y a deux fusils de noah va tenter une
manoeuvre dont kwassa séparant de ce
post est là bas l'autre qui va passer
qui l'a contournée et qui avance et s'il
envoie dans la côture ni les tirs et
puis en fait le but c'est que l'autre en
avançant il va se faire repérer un peu
et ils les poussent vers à celui qui
possède une sorte de mini voitures à
deux avec un batteur et un poster donc
tu vas voir ça c'est fini
il y risque d'y avoir quelques petites
semaines où tout ça va me peser toujours
marché et tous pourront voir que
quelques-uns donc c'est la contrepartie
on vient dans un endroit
un endroit sympa en contrepartie on a
quand même un boulot à faire et des fois
être sympa des fois un peu moins et donc
un bon il faut faire la part des choses
pour maxime c'est un moment important
dans quelques minutes il va tirer son
premier gros gibier à chaque fois on
essaie toujours de faire quand même un
beau tir pour pour la toilette pour
premier en particulier
l'attentât semblait bien longue
quelque chose ne va pas il s'en va seul
apte à tirer le mal je suis venu ces
deux pas derrière là bas tu avais repéré
deux sur la crête là bas et quand je
suis arrivé en fait et le troupeau il
était là dans la petite contre les
petits cercles et rob est en fait je me
suis levé j'ai ici je me lève d'un coup
ils vont se barrer donc je me suis
progressivement ils s'attaquent avait
quelque chose qui n'allait pas et puis
un produit a fait quoi je la fais mais m
il s'écroule et je tire là bas il a fait
venir tout allait s'écrouler la belle
balade traversé l'épaule tu vois c'est
le coeur insiste ici toujours le coeur
ou les organes vitaux
il adresse un petit peu mais après ils
s'arrêtent ils s'arrêtent de suite doit
vous reconnaître l'âge cinéma c'est
super facile chez la corne en fait tu
vois tu as toutes les petites rayures et
puis un moment tu as entre parents
travers qu'on fait là là en fait ça la
première comment tu vois ce parti c'est
ce qui a poussé la première année la
seconde année il ya ça qui a poussé et
là tu vois ses encours de pouce
donc tu vois la corne junkie qui a là
elle est un peu blanchâtre là donc ça
c'est sa troisième année donc il était
3e maxime doit penser que son camarade à
quelque chose d'indiens lorsqu'il voit
benoît rendant les honneurs au mouvement
en lui plaçant des fleurs
dans et sur sa blessure
mais il s'agit simplement d'une
tradition pratiqués en allemagne en
alsace et dans les pays de l'est pour un
premier contact avec l'archipel des
kerguelen
la météo a été clémente ça ne sera
sûrement pas toujours comme ça mais pour
l'instant tout le monde en profite
[Musique]
on côtoie aussi bien les manceaux les
défendent merck que nos colocataires
donc c'est le côté c'est un côté
sympathique aussi il ça permet de varier
aussi parce qu'on peut pas passer un an
tout seul parmi les manceaux ou des
éléphants de mer sans voir personne et
on peut pas non plus passer un an sur
base a côtoyé toujours les mêmes
personnes donc eh bien ça fait ça
équilibre un peu la balance et on
profite des deux et quand il y en a un
qu'il passe moins bien on se réfugie
dans l'os oui avant de venir on passe un
petit un petit entretien psychologique
bombe mais pour connaître un peu nos
motivations de capacité à vis bombay en
communauté quand même c'est quand même
le principal resté bloqué pendant un an
avec les mêmes personnes ou quand même
être relativement sociable mais l écoute
de personnes qui s'entendent pas sur 50
c'est tout à fait normal on peut pas
s'entendre avec tout le monde faut pas
être non plus bon bah une grande gueule
toujours à chaque fois il faut savoir
aussi
1 l faut savoir arrêter faut savoir se
calme et rien dire et puis et puis
laisser passer l'orage
donc bon c'est vrai que chacun d'eux
d'efforts à faire on va se côtoyer tout
le temps ça va être vraiment un en petit
groupe et donc ça pour une durée d'un an
donc bon on va voir normalement ça va
bien se passer
et les filles ça va me rappeler
l'internât et pendant un an et y'aura y
aura pas énormément de filles sur la
base donc on verra si c'est une bonne
chose ou une mauvaise chose pour
l'instant ça fait un mois on va pas on
va pas on va pas crier 'allah là ils
montrent des signes et tout mais bon
tout le monde a réussi à tenir un an les
50 dernières missions alors on va
réussir à tenir aussi
pour les hivernants comment les appels
il faut apprendre à vivre en communauté
les différents occupants de la base
viennent de tous horizons de classe
sociale de métier de formation et de
culture différents et puis à part le
travail
les occupations sont rares autant dire
que pour venir vivre ici
il vaut mieux manifesté de l'intérêt
pour la nature même dans des conditions
difficiles car les seules sorties que
l'on puisse imaginer se feront souvent
dans le froid et dans le vent le reste
du temps il reste les parties de cartes
ou d'isolement devant un bon livre dans
sa chambre
et puis aussi l' angoisse de l'accident
de la maladie ici même s'il ya un
médecin pour les premières urgences
tous rappellent qu'au bout du monde il
ne faut pas attendre de secours avant
deux semaines
parfois pour certains les kerguelen sont
même devenus une dernière demeure
mais pourtant si cette église a été
construite c'est plutôt pour célébrer un
événement heureux en 1957
une jeune femme a traversé les mers pour
épouser celui qu'elle aimait et que sa
lointaine mission tenait éloigné d'elle
depuis l'église chapelle notre dame du
vent
[Musique]
al'approche de noël la tradition veut
qu'une équipe de chasseurs à y tuer un
rennes pour la consommation de la base
[Musique]
cette fois ils seront 4
benoît maxime david des huées
bien sûr les rênes sur la piste dès
qu'elle va se lancer l'équipe ne sont
pas originaires des kerguelen ils ont
été importés par les hommes un an avant
les mouflons au départ ils étaient eux
aussi cantonnés sur l'île haute mais
c'était sans compter sur leur capacité à
nager
c'est ainsi qu'une partie d'entre eux
ont gagné la grande terre la plus grande
des îles
alors il faut marcher marcher et marché
encore au bout de six heures
hugues à l'arrière-garde donne des
signes de faiblesse et ses compagnons
doivent l'attendre
il ya un trou pour là bas au dessus des
au dessus des cascades à la ba voila il
y en a une à une quinzaine à au moins
une quinzaine voire plus peut-être six
ans rencontré d'autres troupeaux et peut
y en avoir plus
quinze ou vingt quoi je me dirige vers
nous là ça serait bien ça il faut se
rapprocher
on va bien voir on va essayer de
remonter la rivière la bascule et on a
égalé un balai
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que maxime
approche des reines pour benoît c'est
une nouvelle occasion de le faire tirer
faux bond à le vend le mieux c'est qu'on
ne sait pas donc je prends des maximes
donc je vais expliquer après toi tu
pourrais en fait le couvrir pouvait
ressentir donc je me servais c'est de
faire une belle balle quoi et donc tu
pour ressentir au cas où il ne pourrait
quoi on a au moins assuré une bête pour
une bête à la base donc voilà pour ce
moment là ça va être bon ils sont pas
loin d'être un peu discret on se tient
un contact radio tout un donc sur canal
10 et puis voilà au premier m
ça fait bizarre de voir des règne ici
quoi ça fait enfin normalement si je
fais pas de mouvements brusques et août
avant ça il remarque quand même pas que
cantat va s'avérer quoi c'est bon on
s'en fout
cet humour qui font ouais mais ça m'a
aussi khan un des plus grands rien qu'au
milieu du troupeau
on va me citez pas s'en aller
faisant des pauses au compteur qui sont
alertés
avec un peu de chance ça s'est passé je
vois quitter sa montée vers la rivière
saas encore environ 5 heures
bon mon sac mais c'est bien coincé
plouay
allez
parce qu'ils vont prendre après deux
heures d'un proche
il faut bien l'admettre les reines se
sont volatilisés le moral n'est pas au
plus haut la seule chose que maxime
verra aujourd'hui ce sont les dégâts
causés par les rênes sur la végétation
locale en particulier la aurel cette
plante est sûrement l'une des plus
anciennes de l'archipel en les grattes
ans avec les palettes donc la palette
c'est à l'avant du bois qui broutent
d'abord une partie de la partie verte et
ensuite ils viennent détruire la touffe
pour manger les racines
sachant que toute la zone qui a été
couché et condamnez moi apparus dès la
fin de la première glaciation elle a
bientôt recouvert jusqu'au sommet de
l'île grâce à sa capacité à résister au
vent mais aujourd'hui elles se raréfient
à cause des reines
[Musique]
e
plume à peine de rêver lille est grande
comme la corse alors il faut prendre son
mal en patience et s'économiser
le programme du lendemain est encore
bien chargé avec vers 4 heures
et puis départ vers 4h30 on fera un
petit tour de 2h30 2h30 3h et à faire on
reviendra si jamais on n'a rien vu on
repassera par les parlements du château
puis et puis rentrer
[Musique]
au matin le groupe décide pourtant de se
séparer
hugues est trop fatigué il préfère
rentrer benoît l'accompagnera maxime
reste avec david
[Musique]
sur le chemin de david et maxime un
renne mort de mort naturelle indiquent
qu'ils sont sur la bonne voie pour
passer l'hiver
ça serait mieux si on les trouvait sur
pied il transite je sais pas si tu as
fait attention on a énormément de traces
la défense peut être de trouver quelques
animaux en meilleur état que celui là
allez c'est parti
effectivement le troupeau n'est pas loin
pour maxime
c'est enfin l'occasion tant attendue
ailier stop
ouais mais le talent est un peu perdue
non
pas mal
elle est maigre
c'est vrai qu'on en sort plus divers a
priori donc ressenti de l'autre côté la
tête
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire combien
il y a deux reines sur l'île dix mille
cent mille impossible de les compter
leur recensement est devenue trop
complexe aussi curieux que cela puisse
paraître la viande va supporter le
voyage du retour jusqu'à la base ici la
température est tellement fraîche qu'on
ne risque pas les problèmes de
conservation pour maxime cette partie de
chasse aura surtout été l'occasion de
voir de près les conséquences de
l'importation des espèces sur
l'environnement originel
les végétaux aussi ont été concernés par
l'invasion d'espèces concurrentes
c'est la raison pour laquelle deux
scientifiques de la base ont constitué
bien à l'écart de tout danger de mélange
intempestifs un carré expérimental là
ils suivent l'évolution des espèces
locales lorsqu'elles sont en milieu
protégé
le rêve de tous consisterait à
reconstituer la végétation d'origine
mais sans doute est-il déjà trop tard
éradiquant une espèce qui est introduite
il ya de très nombreuses années on peut
parvenir
à l'écosystème qui avait en fait avant
l'introduction de cette espèce c'est
difficile de penser quand même
d'imaginer qu'on puisse retourner un
état original de lille
d'une part les mains lui faire introduit
notamment les lapins c'est très
difficile serait très difficile à
éradiquer
et puis les plantes c'est quasiment
impossible
aujourd'hui le projet le plus sage
semble bien consistait à réparer le
mieux possible les erreurs commises
depuis plus de deux siècles étape
importante dans cette démarche
l'archipel des kerguelen a été classée
réserve naturelle en octobre 2006
première étape protéger les zones encore
intacte de toute nouvelle invasion
pour benoît laventure des kerguelen est
fini pour en tout cas
elle va continuer sans lui
un autre monde l'attend celui qu'il
avait abandonnée voici plus d'un an
là-bas si loin derrière l'horizon
c'est dans les mains de maxime qui est
désormais le destin de cette terre
appelée à renaître
même si comme dans l'histoire des hommes
eux mêmes le paradis originel a jadis
été perdu
[Musique]